ahora vamos a empezar a revisar ecología
que es el estudio de cómo interactúa un
tipo de vida con otro o cómo interactúan
las cosas vivas entre sí dentro de su
entorno y podrían pensar cómo la vida
interactúa con cosas vivas y a estas se
les llama factores bióticos y tenemos la
palabra bio qué significa vida y cómo
interactúa con cosas no vivas a las que
llamamos factores abióticos el prefijo a
indica negación así que a bióticos
significa no vivo factores no vivos y
estos son los términos técnicos pero si
piensas en ti mientras ves este vídeo tú
estás en un entorno interactuando con él
y hay muchos factores abióticos a tu
alrededor que puedes notar como el aire
que respiras la temperatura tu acceso al
agua pero también hay factores bióticos
incluso si piensas que estás solo en una
habitación no estás completamente solo
hay bacterias a tu alrededor que
probablemente no puedas ver
probablemente hay otras formas de vida
tal vez tengas una planta en la
habitación esos son factores bióticos
que interactúan contigo
a planta en la habitación probablemente
está produciendo el oxígeno que estás
respirando
o tú estás produciendo el dióxido de
carbono que la planta es capaz de fijar
para crecer y también está interactuando
con factores abióticos como la luz del
sol que usa para la fotosíntesis y para
fijar el carbono estudiamos está
profundidad en biología y en realidad la
ecología es un poco como una síntesis de
prácticamente todo lo que hemos
aprendido en biología porque toma la
vida para estudiarla en otro nivel ya no
estamos hablando de organismos
individuales e incluso no es solo la
población o la comunidad sino que
estamos hablando de un sistema mayor que
es increíblemente complejo y por eso es
tan interesante estudiarlo ahora todas
estas imágenes que tenemos aquí son
cosas que asociamos con un ecosistema
aquí abajo tenemos un arrecife de coral
y algunos de los seres vivos que hay los
podemos ver fácilmente aquí tenemos el
coral aquí los peces pero también hay
vida que no vemos hay bacterias en esta
agua que no son visibles en esta
fotografía y los factores abióticos son
cosas como la temperatura del agua
o simplemente la existencia del agua o
el contenido de sal en el agua o algunos
otros minerales que están aquí en estas
fotografías que tenemos acá no vemos la
vida animal necesariamente pero seguro
que la vamos a encontrar si cavamos en
este terreno o si buscamos en estos
arbustos vamos a encontrar la vida
animal encontraremos insectos y
encontraremos otros animales los árboles
son vida así que van a ser parte del
ecosistema si estudiamos ecología vamos
a pensar en cómo estos árboles
interactúan con el agua cómo interactúan
con otras especies cómo es que les
proporcionan refugio a otras especies o
cómo les proporcionan comida o cómo son
dependientes de alguna manera de otro
tipo de vida para poder crecer tenemos
el mismo caso con las setas cómo es que
los hongos viven de la rama de este
árbol junto con el musgo y todo lo que
hay aquí todo esto es el estudio de la
ecología el estudio de los ecosistemas
ahora cuando las personas hablan de
ecología les gusta hablar de ella en
diferentes escalas así que ahora
pensemos en diferentes escalas de un
ecosistema o incluso más allá de un
ecosistema entonces aquí tengo algunas
fotografías de cosas que vemos cuando
miramos un espectáculo de la vida
salvaje y cómo estamos familiarizados
con esto cuando menos en televisión con
suerte visitaremos algo hacía en algún
momento de nuestra vida simplemente
pensemos en los diferentes personajes
que tenemos aquí a las diferentes
escalas ecológicas así que la escala
basal es el individuo entonces si
estamos hablando de estos elefantes un
individuo sería un elefante aquí lo
tenemos ahora la siguiente escala es la
población y si estamos revisando el tema
de nuestra sabana africana aquí tenemos
un individuo pero la población serían
los miembros de la misma especie que
viven en esta área así que en este caso
la población incluye estos elefantes que
vemos en la fotografía y tal vez hay un
par de elefantes que nos salieron en la
foto y yo diría particularmente que esos
son los elefantes africanos así que son
los miembros de la misma especie que
viven en el mismo lugar y para el
clasificador o el científico
quienquiera que está estudiando es
necesario definir que queremos decir con
que vivan en el mismo lugar podríamos
decir que son los elefantes que viven a
unas pocas millas de este abrevadero
podrías definirlo como los elefantes que
viven en un área más extensa digamos el
este de áfrica o sudáfrica cualquier
lugar
entonces definimos la población como
todos los miembros de una especie que
viven en un área en un área que está
sujeta a ser definida por nosotros ahora
el siguiente nivel es la comunidad y la
comunidad son todas las cosas vivas que
viven en esta área por supuesto en un
área definida así que por ejemplo si
este león y esta jirafa viven en el área
que usamos para definir la población
entonces serían miembros de la comunidad
así que déjenme encerrarlos en un
círculo ellos serían miembros de la
comunidad y no sólo lo serán los
animales grandes que ves aquí sino que
estará incluido todo lo vivo que se
encuentra en esta área estará incluida
la vegetación que hay aquí las bacterias
los hongos cualquier animal que vive en
el agua que ves allí
y si seguimos a un nivel mayor de
inclusión entonces llegamos al
ecosistema llegamos al ecosistema y un
ecosistema son todas las cosas vivas en
esta comunidad todas las cosas vivas en
un área pero también consideramos las
cosas no vivas los factores abióticos
así que incluimos las piedras el aire el
clima las nubes y el agua que es parte
de este abrevadero y puedes pensar que
los factores abióticos afectan y claro
que afectan a los factores bióticos si
no tienes agua o si la temperatura es
muy fría o muy caliente probablemente
será difícil que prospere algún tipo de
vida pero esta afectación va en dos
sentidos los factores bióticos afectan a
los factores abióticos tenemos oxígeno
en nuestro entorno debido a la vida en
la tierra y probablemente también afecta
a la composición química de algunos
factores abióticos como el agua el suelo
o cualquier cosa y si queremos llegar a
un nivel mayor que el ecosistema
entonces alguna vez habrás oído hablar
de la biosfera puedes pensar en ella
como un meta ecosistema
a veces yo lo visualizo como todos los
ecosistemas que de alguna manera están
conectados unos con otros como un
ecosistema que contiene todo y la
biosfera más conocida o más bien a la
única a la que nos referimos es el
planeta tierra que es en sí una biosfera
tiene múltiples ecosistemas y una vez
más los ecosistemas dependen de lo que
un investigador quiera definir como
ecosistema podría definir un ecosistema
como algo alrededor de cierto río en una
cierta área o podría definirlo como una
región más extensa pero todos los
ecosistemas en el mundo son parte de la
biosfera que conocemos como la tierra y
esta es autosuficiente porque no
pensamos que haya muchas influencias de
afuera de la tierra aunque aún allí
tenemos que darle crédito al sol que
ciertamente provee de factores abióticos
no tendríamos la vida en la tierra como
la conocemos sin el sol y también hay
cosas como la luna el efecto
gravitacional podríamos considerar eso
como un factor abiótico si las mareas no
tendríamos la vida como la conocemos
pero algo que es realmente gracioso
ustedes saben que me gusta la ciencia
ficción es pensar qué tipos de biosferas
podríamos tener si pensamos más allá de
la tierra y aquí tenemos una
representación en realidad esto es el
sitio web de la nasa como los humanos
podrían crear biosfera fuera del planeta
y esto es algo interesante y aquí
tenemos terreno creado artificialmente y
lo rotamos para que haya una percepción
de gravedad pero de cualquier manera el
estudio de los ecosistemas el estudio de
la biosfera el estudio de la ecología en
general es increíblemente fascinante
porque cuando tienes toda esta
complejidad cada cosa viva es
increíblemente compleja y de hecho si
quieres incluso algunas veces puedes
considerar parte de una cosa viva como
un ecosistema si observas la superficie
de tu mano
tienes bacterias viviendo ahí que
dependen de ti de alguna manera y en
realidad tú te puedes beneficiar de las
bacterias o resultar dañado por las
bacterias de alguna manera así que
existen diferentes escalas pero una vez
que empiezas a factorizar todo junto
esto viene a ser un sistema
increíblemente hermoso
complejo con frecuencia balanceado
algunas veces desbalanceado que tiene
propiedades emergentes que de alguna
manera describen a un ecosistema como un
todo